let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right um now uh camila harris this
week went to pay her respects to ruth
bader ginsburg and afterwards decided to
solemnly and very respectfully
use ginsburg's death for political gain
as
is the tradition in washington very very
very sacred tradition
listen to this we are about to undertake
the task
of finding her replacement on the united
states supreme
court of course it's hard
to say those words in truth
ruth bader ginsburg cannot be replaced
she was an original a one-of-a-kind
she combined a steel spine
with an ability to extend an open hand
never a closed fist
she demonstrated you could both hold
firm
to your principles and still hear
those with whom you disagree that is a
lesson
that should be ringing in our ears
but it looks like this president and his
party
are not interested in hearing any of the
lessons
from justice ginsburg already the
president
and his party have chosen to ignore
justice ginsburg's final wish
to hold off the nomination to replace
her
until after the next president is chosen
a wish by the way shared by the american
people
this talking point i mean my god it is
so stupid it's beyond the bounds of
normal stupid
uh and and they're still going with it
they're they're gonna run this thing
they're gonna run with it this final
wish gambit
all the way through uh there is no final
wish clause of the constitution i don't
know how many times we have to explain
this the supreme court is not the
make-a-wish foundation
final wishes are constitutionally
irrelevant
um so this this could it could not be
less relevant than it is
the supreme court seats are not
bequeathed to an
heir you can't leave them in your will
right so it's not going to be
uh yeah grandma left you the jewelry box
and
oh look at that a supreme court seat
congratulations
no that's not how this works uh so just
what a monumentally stupid thing
good lord okay speaking of monumentally
stupid things number two this is a this
this is real amazingly usa today ran a
fact check on a babylon b
article the babylonian article which
said that the ninth circuit court of
appeals overturned the death of supreme
court justice ruth bader ginsburg
now they overturned her death
usa today did some research on this ran
down some leads hit the pavement you
know
and they concluded it's probably
probably not true
so this is the usa today article says
the claim the ninth circuit court of
appeals overturned the death of supreme
court justice ruth bader ginsburg
the headline of an article published by
satire website the babylon b is a nod to
the contentious history between the
trump administration the u.s court of
appeals
the babylon b is the world's best satire
site according to its website supreme
court justice
uh ginsburg who died of pancreatic
cancer september 18th is actually alive
the article suggests because the ninth
circuit overturned her death
um in a close decision the judges on the
court have ruled rbg's death
unconstitutional and
will block trump from nominating a
replacement the article says
ninth circuit judge kim mclean wardlaw
was credited with issuing the ruling on
the basis that ginsburg death was an
affront to the constitution
um and then it goes on from there
and it finally gets to the verdict there
is no record of any ward law opinion on
ginsberg's death on the website of the
ninth circuit
but she they actually looked it up on
the website they looked this up on the
website to see if this really happened
but she participated in a panel
discussion friday about ginsburg's life
produced by the ucla law school
uh there was no mention of reviving
ginsburg during the discussion
okay now if i wanted to try really hard
to defend usa today here
i'm not sure why i would want to do that
but if i did i might say that well you
know what
some people in this country are really
really stupid
um and so there may be people who are
dumb enough to read that b
article and not understand that it's
satire so maybe this is a reflection of
america's stupidity not usa today's
but i can't let them off the hook that
easily i think it's a combination of
both factors because
first of all anyone who's dumb enough to
believe that a court
overturned a woman's death isn't going
to have the wherewithal to then go and
research the claim right like a person
that dumb isn't going to go hmm
let me cross-check this claim and see if
it's reported in any reputable sources
no that's just they're just gonna read
it go
uh okay
and then stuff with another cheeto into
their mouth and keep scrolling
that's that's what's gonna happen so
unfortunately usa today
uh still must be blamed for this
stupidity number three the new york post
headline
nearly 70 percent of americans say
they're done with coffee shops after
becoming at-home baristas
it says half americans have become
coristas
during 2020 quarristas like quarantine
baristas
um okay first of all just
we got to stop right there if you have
ever called yourself a quarista
that is an automatic eviction from the
human race i'm not saying you should be
executed
i'm not not saying that mainly i'm just
saying you can't be a human anymore we
don't want you in in the human you can
pick another species
you know maybe see if the llamas will
take you i don't know
anyway a survey of 2000 coffee drinkers
revealed 49 of respondents
have become at-home baristas during
quarantine using their time inside to
develop their coffee making skills
two-thirds of those have so much faith
in their new found talent
they plan to continue using their
barista knowledge to make coffee
in their own kitchen even once the
pandemic is over okay listen
making coffee at home we used to just
call that
making coffee at home you're not an
at-home barista now that you turn the
coffee pot on
that's not am i an at-home mechanical
engineer because i changed the batteries
in my
remote no come on
number four the daily wire let's see
daily wire says actor jason isaacs the
man who previously called ivanka trump a
brainless barbie
said that non-mask wearer should be
hanging in the streets or in prison
speaking of the british daytime chats
speaking on the british daytime chat
show lorraine uh isaac said that he is
actually less annoyed by non-mask
wearers
than he is by people who don't wear them
properly adding that non-mask wearer
should be in prison or executed
wow you know maybe i can't judge him for
threatening to have people executed for
superfluous reasons
i do that like 14 times a show i just
did it a second ago actually but
it's different when i do it you know
that that's my thing
right that's my being in being an
enraged lunatic
is my whole deal and everyone knows that
if something is your whole deal then
it's okay that's that's the rule
everyone knows that that's
that's the old excuse and it's a good
one i think you know if you're just like
a jerk to everybody all the time
then whenever anyone accuses you of
being a jerk
someone else can go oh he's just being
himself
as if the fact that you're horrible a
lot makes it okay
if you're only horrible sometimes it's
not but if you're if you're that way all
the time you know you're consistent
about it then it's okay
um anyway this is obviously overblown
and if we're going to be doling out
harsh mask-related penalties i'd rather
dull them out in the other direction
like i took my kids to the beach
a couple days over the weekend i took my
kids to the beach all four kids by
myself to the beach by the way
um kids seven and younger uh i i took i
don't know why i decided to do this but
we had to get them out of the house
because my wife was getting getting the
house ready to sell
staging and everything and um
anyway i took the kids to the beach but
i i couldn't help but notice even though
i'm i'm distracted by trying to keep
track of all
all the kids i can still take the time
to be annoyed and angry by things
uh that's my special skill and the
people on the beach or near the beach
like walking on the boardwalk
wearing masks okay um that if there's
gonna be penalties
if i was in charge the penalty would be
for that because you look ridiculous
and there's absolutely no reason to do
that you're at the beach
okay you really rather than breathing in
that nice fresh ocean air you're gonna
breathe in your own fumes you really
think that's healthier for you
really number five finally here's an
article that escaped my attention a year
ago
um but i just saw it now because making
the rounds again online
telling us of a certain group that i'm
guessing probably with covet has been on
hiatus
so if you're looking to join the group
you'll probably have to wait but
these people exist and they're out there
um it is uh here's what it says from the
inquirer.com it says
twice a month half a dozen men gather in
plymouth meeting uh in a plymouth
meeting to
help each other work through past
traumas their chosen method of healing
cuddles it may seem odd but members of
the men's
therapeutic cuddle group say the
practice has helped them cope with
everything from childhood sexual abuse
to the loss of family members when they
were young
the two-year-old group draws men from
various backgrounds a 37 year old mormon
57 year old married father of three a 62
year old retiree there's a range of
sexual orientations
at a time when traditional ideas of
manhood are facing scrutiny
in such terms as toxic masculinity or
becoming widely known
the group aims to provide new ways for
men to express themselves
unlike professional cuddling services
which is a thing professional cuddling
services
the group charges no fees that's good
and members are not required to
undergo training
can you get a degree in cuddling i bet
you can i bet you can
although the meetups are not open to the
public uh the group held a demonstration
for the enquirer
at the beginning of the session everyone
agreed not to engage in sexual touch
and to ask for consent before each
action
they gathered in a huddle and breathed
meditatively
the cuddling started with men pairing up
to do the motorcycle hold
this sounds horrifying already uh in
what in which one man sits with his back
against another man's chest
as if they were riding together on a
motorcycle
some massaged their parent their their
partner's
shoulders or or hands while others
stroked the other person's beard
many clothes stroked the other person's
beard
many closed their eyes as the room fell
into silence after 15 minutes they
switched to a new partner
for the second half of the session the
men cuddled as one large group
in what they call a puppy pile
men lay with their heads in each other's
laps chatted and joked
oh my god in heaven god help us god help
us all
and you know you know you know all these
dudes use emojis
okay so i you know i'm right about this
i i don't know do i need to spell out
the issues here do i need to
what you find here actually illustrated
in in very disturbing and graphic detail
um is is this fundamental
misunderstanding on the left
about masculinity and femininity and
they think oh well you know
we just have to tear down the artifice
of masculinity we have to
the artificial construct of masculinity
we have to tear down um because that's
the only reason
that dudes don't cuddle they really want
to deep down but they don't because
they're worried that society will frown
on
you know frown upon it no no see that's
not it yes
society will frown upon it and should
but that's not the point
society could give the puppy pile filled
with dudes a big thumbs up
and i still would decline because the
whole reason we don't associate men with
cuddling
isn't that men don't cuddle because we
don't associate them with it
it's that we it it's that we we don't
associate them with it
because they don't do it okay for the
most part there is something deeply
ingrained
naturally ingrained in our net in our
masculine nature that makes us far less
touchy-feely than women
there are exceptions sometimes those
exceptions take horrific form like this
but
you're never going to build a society of
cuddling men because most men don't have
that in them
thank god so we will continue to confine
ourselves
to handshakes fist bumps
um the off awkward sort of half
handshake half hug thing
or my specialty is the series of aborted
greetings
that you that you get when you know
there's two guys that don't know how the
other likes to greet
and so you get the kind of going in for
the handshakes the
kind of handshake and then it looks like
they're going for a hug and then you
back up and then it's just kind of
and you're you know it's like you're a
video game sort of like
freezing um that's my move
my move in other words is to make
everyone feel a lot less comfortable
than they did before i entered the room
but
they're still a lot more comfortable
than they would be if i walked into the
room
and asked who's up for a good cuddle uh
i
i think that would make it far less
comfortable i think hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated